I have the craziest exchanges with
Sandler he was at my parent teacher
meeting and that just we have the
craziest oh you were texting back and
forth while it was going on not while I
was going off of what we were they're
all sitting there saying and if there's
a dad out there would be willing to come
in every Thursday that would really be a
big help and Stan Lee yells out Cody in
the back of the room and the teachers
were all started like ooh like that news
I oh you should do that Conan and I'm
like um I knew his wife is mad at him
and everyone's chuckling but but anyway
after the meeting I just said you may
have fool out of me who's that no nobody
I put you up on top you'll see and then
later on I just get his text for him
that I like he said love you bud and I
said you made a fool out of me tonight
anyone forget anytime soon he said I
make you a star you will eat those words
thank me now it's your last chance no
one ever knew who you were till I
mentioned your name mental issue so I
wrote back it's true now they know me
I'm sorry I got mad I think I just
panicked you were so good to me and then
the next day well did you get laid
enjoy the top but it's a long fall am i
right back pre girls like me because of
what you did I mean all the papers this
ride will never end
then he wrote back did it end yet like I
said it would
now you're not such a big shot I laugh
at you because it's all just a memory
and penises for peeing only now all the
Sun in products you you are using me
nothing now girls think you are a girl
I'm the catch of the day now tell that
to your friends at the TV s sorry sucker
my right back how could it end this is
like a 2:00 in the morning
how could it could it end so quickly
today I am nothing the restaurant said
they had no room but I can see through
the window that they are empty
someone put dog [ __ ] in my hat I look
for pictures in the magazines but all
the photos are review my city wants to
grow up to be Sandler this turtle sends
off of one comment to the parent-teacher
meeting Cody
Oh
[Music]